now welcome back Foodies unite Las Vegas
Restaurant Week kicks off today and it's
huge here to talk about it and how it
helps all of those in need Kate Hibbert
Gaines joining us from Three Square Food
Bank which is where it benefits and of
course all this incredible food two
different restaurants I love this spare
and wolf and half bird chicken and beer
and John you have an incredible John
Anthony I should say have an incredible
display which we'll get to momentarily
let's talk about the reason that we
created this restaurant week we I mean
we live in an incredible eating City we
do we live in this culinary Mecca right
and it's just incredible the options are
out there but the unfortunate reality
Behind these restaurants and behind the
stripe is that there's one out of seven
individuals in our community that don't
always know where their next meal is
coming from one out of four kids that go
home to a food insecure household
so here we are eating but giving back so
that folks don't have to face that same
dilemma when they open their Pantry
every day so all these restaurants you
said 230 have joined in and and they're
what donating a portion to Three Square
that's right the restaurant set up a
menu that's either 20 to 80 in price
range okay three courses sometimes four
and then they all are giving back four
five or six dollars and that's gonna
create multiple meals back into our
community so you're gonna go out do
something good for somebody else I love
that Kate how much is one meal for you
guys if somebody donates money how much
what does that equal yeah right now
every dollar donated we can turn that
into three meals wow yeah that's
incredible incredible and also
incredible this food here oh my gosh now
okay John let's start with half bird
chicken and beer this is a relatively
newer restaurant both here are in
Chinatown Spring Mountain half bird
chicken and beer brainchild of Chef
Brian Howard uh Love of All Things
chicken and the comfort food that comes
from that yes uh and then sparrow and
wolf which has been open about six years
now now on the same street still doing
very well oh it's just wonderful to be
there it's just become such a part of
the community so and being part of the
community is super important to us Chef
Brian actually sits on the board at
three Square oh great we are very active
within that that sphere and and for us
we're doing the full top donation on
either menu so at twenty dollars at half
bird we're giving back six dollars so
that's going to create for each person
coming in to dine 18 meals oh my God
you're gonna see our chicken nugs our uh
that's what these are chicken nugs all
of the sauces
our version of a hot chicken sandwich
with a bit of Szechuan Chili Pepper our
gravy fries that we get the chicken
drippings on there and of course you got
to finish with a chocolate chip cookie
and a little sea salt absolutely down
with a cockfight pilsner that's a
collaboration with huddle Brewery that
we do that's specific for the restaurant
yeah and you guys have that cool outdoor
pack s oh it's great for this time of
year yeah when it's nice and warm come
out watch the nights win game two
tonight
[Applause]
we're gonna do a three-course menu it's
intensely amount of food so sixty
dollars per guest uh we're showcasing
the Hudson Valley duck breast our
bluefin tuna tartar one of my favorites
the oxtail hummus it's Rich it's creamy
it makes you feel like you did a little
something wrong yeah I love a little
guilt with my food wash it down with a
great bottle of wine a little bit again
we're fortunate to do it we're excited
to be a part of it and not just you know
donating back but bringing in guests who
maybe haven't dined at those restaurants
before and they save up all year round
to do it where you love watching those
guests walk through the door you get
some great food items too for it and it
goes to a good cause John thank you this
looks amazing by the way their chef was
here putting all this together and he
smells just as good as this food oh
that's right
thank you
God information restaurant week goes
until the 16th the 16th okay all right
folks we're taking a break stay with us
we'll be right back